so let's start
um so in this is the second part of
uh let's talk about homomorphic
encryption and
here we're going to talk about
bootstrapping and foliomorphic
encryption and then some
other stuff as well
not working again well it worked for one
hour
yeah on switch is always a good bit um
so what we want to have um
so far we had an encryption scheme that
can evaluate
circuits of bounded depth or complexity
and we could make the
uh we could make the parameter as large
as we want them to get
any polynomial depth perhaps but uh but
it's still limited once you set your
parameters they're fixed and you can
only evaluate
our messages early and valued functions
up to some complexity
uh what we want is a fully morphic
encryption where
you can evaluate unbound the depth
circuit essentially any circuit
not limited by the size of parameters
that you chose
and so far as i said you can only do
bound depth in particular the uh
very easy calculation that we had in the
last slide
of the previous hour uh you can do
things in
depth log of q base
n plus one and the question is how do we
make it fooling morphic and
the way is almost the only way that we
know how to make it
a foliomorphic encryption uh
is using bootstrapping
so before we go there let's uh talk
philosophy for a little bit
um
you can ask questions like
self-referential questions can we
ever fully understand ourselves i mean
you know
the smarter we get the more complex our
brain becomes
the more we can understand things on the
other hand there is more to understand
at this
so can we ever get to a point where i
can fully understand
my own brain or is it always
you know the complexity that you need to
understand thing is always
uh bigger than the complexity of things
that you can understand with that piece
of
do i need to understand hardware the
encryption
uh and actually self-referential issues
are very
influential and and have consequences uh
in
in mathematics and in computer science
right i mean you can think of
good as incompleteness theorem or the
halting problem these are all
self-referential thing where you can
show that something cannot
fully process itself to some uh
by some meaning uh so let's uh
go back to crypto can homomorphic
encryption
ever decrypts itself um
well on some level the question
does make sense decryption is a
procedure you can ask
whether or not a homomorphic encryption
scheme
can have enough homomorphic capacity to
evaluate its own decryption procedure
it's a question that makes sense
is it self-referential in a good way we
can do that
or the cell phone professional in a bad
way there's always one step ahead of us
i mean
in order to make the evaluation
depth something we need to get the
parameters large enough and maybe
then the complexity of decryption gets
bigger and we can never
catch our tails
the answer as we all know is yes
i'm going to call the process of running
the evaluation procedure on the
decryption
recryption recryption and bootstrapping
are sort of
interchangeable but at least when i give
talks i prefer to call the specific
procedure recription and bootstrapping
is sort of the concept
so so far we have bounded processing we
can evaluate bounded depth circuits so
we have some bounded depth that we want
to achieve
we can set up the apparatus to achieve
that depth
and then when we have uh homo when we
have encryption of these beats
mu uh we can get we can set up the
uh procedure for evaluating ethernet run
these encryptions through that procedure
and we get a cipher text and creating
and encrypting the
result and the evaluated cipher text is
noisy so we have noise
and the original things were green
because they had little noise in them uh
the new thing is orange because it has
more noise on it
and you can still decrypt it it's not so
noisy that it can decrypt but if you try
to compute more on it
you're gonna get something which is so
noisy that it's red and you cannot
decrypt it anymore right so this is what
we have so far
uh and the idea of recryption is trying
to refresh the cipher text so as to
reduce its noise
so take a ciphertext and think of the
following uh
function the function has the ciphertext
hardwire in it it's not an input to the
function
what is an input to the function is a
pub is a secret key
and it's going to take an input and try
to use it as a secret key to decrypt
that particular one ciphertext
so this is the function d sub ciphertext
and suppose we have an evaluation
capacity that can handle depth d
circuits
and suppose this function has depth
that's just
slightly below d let's say d minus one
and then what we can we can do is the
following
uh we're going to include in the public
key uh
also an encryption of the secret key
well doing that you have to make the
assumption that the cryptosystem is
still secure
so you have to assume what we call
circular security of the cryptosystem
and we have here the encryption of the
secret key beats these are all green
encryptions with little
noise in them and now we have our
ciphertext
and this is an evaluated ciphertext we
can no longer compute in it but what we
can do
is write down the description of this
function
d sub c and now we have the description
of the function and we have encryption
of the secret key bits and we can pass
this
encryption through the evaluation
procedure
for this function an outcome
well an encryption of the function
applied to the to our inputs
what is the function applied to our
inputs this is an encryption of what you
would get if you decrypt the original
ciphertext
so it's an encryption of the original
message
but because the
um because the depth
of evaluating this decryption function
is just d minus 1
then this has smaller noise than the
original
uh cipher text and notice that we only
applied any kind of processing to the uh
seeker to the fresh encryption of secret
key and now we have one more level
that we can evaluate on this ciphertext
and then we can repeat the process
uh which brings us to uh craig's
bootstrapping theorem which i'm only
going to uh
give him sort of informal uh
way so suppose we have an amorphic
encryption scheme that can evaluate
arithmetic circuit up to some depth d
but
where decryption of every single
ciphertech that can
result from this computation takes at
most depth d minus one
in that case we call this a
bootstrappable
homomorphic encryption scheme and the
theorem says that from a bootstrappable
somatomorphic encryption
you can construct fully on morphic
scheme using bootstrapping
uh if you add the assumption of circular
security
and the technique is what i just showed
you add you
add the encryption of the secret key and
every time a ciphertext gets to be
so noisy that it can still be decrypted
but cannot be evaluated on
you do this uh recryption procedure
and you keep going so with that
okay that's a nice beautiful theorem
can we actually make use of it so do we
have encryption scheme that are
bootstrappable well
uh we can evaluate the decryption
procedure
and let's try to do that for the gsw
scheme that we uh
that we described before so can we
evaluate the decryption procedure of gsw
what is the decryption procedure of gsw
this is what we said so far um
you have a matrix c you have a secret
key
which is a vector t you do a matrix
vector multiplication mode q
and then you check whether the result is
closer to zero or closer to
t prime which is g times t okay
that's a little inconvenient to work
with so let's get it to into a more
convenient form before we start
trying to compute it so first of all
here is an equivalent procedure
let's look at the uh this vector that
has q over two here in the first
coordinate and zero elsewhere
um then you know the inner product
between this and t is exactly q over 2.
this is what i said it's very convenient
to have one there in t
because it lets you do stuff so here's
one thing that you can do
and then once you have this uh
ciphertext matrix let's look at what you
get by
applying this g inverse to
uh to this vector w so basically you
take every entry in w
and you expand it to its binary
representation and then multiply by l
cipher text and now inner product with t
uh
so well there's just algebra here right
i mean you
open uh uh you open the
the parentheses and what you get is an
inner product between g inverse of w
and uh and t times c
and luckily g and g inverse cancel
and eventually what you get out of it uh
is
mu times the inner product between w and
t
plus a little bit of noise
and so let me say something about all of
this algebra
it's necessary and it works but the best
way to think about it is forget the
error
try to do it with the error-free thing
and then put whatever machinery you need
in order to make it work in the error
terms and that's essentially what's
going to happen here
uh and we got back our uh decryption for
the rig of cryptosystem right decryption
for the regular crypto system was
take an inner product between the
ciphertext vector and the secret key
vector this is exactly what we have here
we take
our ciphertext matrix we sort of
preprocess it a little bit to get a
vector
and then an inner product with that
vector and we take the most significant
bit of it
so instead of the previous maybe
somewhat cumbersome
uh decryption procedure now we have this
procedure
uh you you pre-process your
ciphertext by doing an inner product
between that
that ciphertext so by multiplying by
this fixed vector that has nothing to do
with the secret key or anything else
uh and now the new ciphertext is just
a vector when you take an inner product
and take the most significant bit
um you're saying one of the rows of the
gsw ciphertext
is a rugged site yeah that's basically
what i'm saying
in a more algebraic version but yeah um
so here is our new decryption procedure
and we ask ourselves what is the
complexity of doing that so let's
try to think what is it that we're doing
here
we have these two vectors we need to
take inner product
let's say right we're talking about
binary so
when we say we have these two type of
this guy we have
in our hand and we have an encryption of
that so we can you can think about it
this way or you can just think of it as
as a specification of a function where
everything isn't
uh is encoded in
gave it binary this phone so yeah so
what you
do in the in the recryption procedure is
you take your ciphertext
you re preprocess it to get c and then
you apply the recryption procedure on
that scene
the thing that you have encrypted so let
me go back
to here um you don't really need to do
any of
them the the only the only thing you're
doing with your c
is generate the function that you want
to compute so in particular
in this inner product you have this
vector c
that specify what function you're trying
to compute and then you apply everything
to
the fresh encryption of the secret key
and these are encrypted as matrices so
and those you can do
so what are the operations that we're
trying to do here we need to do inner
product think of these things as
represented in binary
well you need to do integer products and
you need to do integer addition and then
you need to
to uh to do a mod q
uh reduction how
difficult how what is the complexity of
doing all these operations well
they're all logarithmic i mean there's
it's log in
the dimension of these vectors on its
log
in the bit length of q
so all you all you do all you get
eventually
is uh depth which is essentially n
plus log q or maybe some constant factor
times n plus log q all right i mean all
these integer
the integer product you can all do in
parallel you need to do one level of uh
you need to do the three of additions
and then you do you need to do a modular
reduction
which has the same complexity as a
product
so this this is well there's the size of
q because you need to
all of these numbers are q uh thing and
you need to do
yeah you need to do
that yeah be log login right yeah it is
login
that's there's a log here you just don't
see it
thank you yeah
thanks uh right
so
right so right given that there's a log
here then
uh yeah it's it's uh
i guess it's the same color as this log
here
um so if the bottom line is that if q
was small enough then this would be
a shallow circuit and you can evaluate
it
but q isn't really small enough i mean
we need to make
q larger to support
a computation so can we actually do it
maybe every time we want to get to some
particular uh
depth we need to increase q and then the
complexity of decryption
so ideally we would like the complexity
to be independent of the evaluation
capacity
um and this is our second rabbit
uh right here this is a magic trick due
to uh
so and what it this is the following
um what we want to compute
is this most significant bit of the
inner product mod q
but we really want q to be smaller so
can we just make it smaller
um there is one way to make it smaller
just
make it smaller you know multiply
everything by p over q
and that's not quite what we want
because well we like integers around it
so a rounded version of p times q
p over q times our ciphertext is uh
i want to look at it as the exact
version plus the rounding error
uh so before that what we had is the
inner product
was a bit times q over 2 plus a little
bit of arrow
plus some you know multiple of q because
we reduced mod q
uh so what do we have now well
now we have this new ciphertext which is
the scaled and rounded version
which is p times q times the original
one plus
the error in our product with the secret
key
uh let's look at the first part p times
q
uh p over q times the previous one well
p over q times the previous one is
exactly what we wanted
it's p over two times our beat
plus uh p over q times
the error so we took the original arrow
and scale it down by the same amount
that we scaled
our modulus so the ratio between evil
and modulus remains the same
uh and then
in addition now we have uh the thing
that was k
times q become became canvas times p so
this is the mod p
reduction uh and the only additive added
thing that we have now is a new error
term
which is the inner product between our
rounding error
and the secret key and the only thing we
need to convince ourselves is that this
is really small error
so that part is definitely small it was
small before and we scaled it down by
exactly the right amount so it's still
small
what about the inner product between the
air the
rounding error and the secret key well
the rounding error is nice surrounding
error is a
small vector it is rounding error i mean
that's most a half or at most one
depending how you round um
so what do we do with the secret key is
it
is the secret key a small vector
well so far it's not really i mean we
said that we choose it at random so it's
not
a small thing in any way uh what do we
do
yeah let's pull another rabbit uh
since we like them so much uh applebaum
cash baker than sahai showed that yeah
sure you need to assume that the secret
key is small go right ahead it's fine
uh there is a reduction saying that this
is just as hard as
as the original version of learning with
errols so let's
choose our secret key this way and once
we did that
uh you choose actually you choose the
the secret key from the same
distribution that you where you choose
your lwe error
so you get something with small
coordinates um
and if you make it
if you set your parameters and you can
set your parameters for lwe or the
errors of polynomial size
uh then the inner product between
the uh rounding error and the secret
keys of polynomial size and therefore
the
q the sorry the p the smaller modulus
you can choose it of size polynomial in
the security parameter
and importantly independent of
your evaluation so here is now
now here's the plan um let's start by
figuring out how large we want t to be
uh so we know what the distribution is
we know how large d is
uh then figure out how large uh
we want p to be well we need the
the p to be larger than the inner
product between a rounding error and our
secret key
plus whatever error we had from before
now we know what the the complexity of
the decryption
procedure is should be because now we
know that the decryption procedure
is inner product mode p and taking the
most significant bit
and now we can set our queue to be large
enough so that uh our cryptosystem would
support that
uh that uh
processing and we'd be fine so
the bottom line is that after some
pre-processing of the
uh of the cipher text so we need to take
the ciphertext that was originally a
matrix we compute
a vector from it then we scale this
vector down and round it
now we have a new ciphertext and that
ciphertext
defined for us a decryption procedure
that's still correct
still gives out the right answer and has
complexity which is smaller than what we
can evaluate with our cryptosystem
uh so we get a complexity that's
independent of the evaluation capacity
uh of our cryptosystem uh
and then and now everything works now we
have something that's in
nc1 some fixed logarithmic in the
security parameter depth and we can grow
our other parameters to be above it uh
and we have a bootstrappable scheme and
we can bootstrap and make it into a
um into a uh
fully homomorphic encryption so let's
just go over uh
um very quickly to see what's the
what's the how does the recryption
procedure looks like well
i'm not going to go too specific about
it i'm just going to say well
it's shallow enough so we can do it so
we we're doing nands
right and anand looks like that it's
you know 1 minus mu 1 times mu 2 and in
this case
1 is represented as this g matrix that
we had before
and and the error
looks like that
and if you have d levels then
at worst you multiply things by m plus 1
to the power d
so you need to take q which to be
m plus 1 to the d which is essentially
polynomial in the security parameter
time to the power of something that's uh
logarithmic in the security
so you get something which is uh
quasi-polynomial
uh and now one thing that uh
is still not that nice in this thing is
that
what is the error the arrow is
essentially polynomial
in size so log number of bits
what's q q is the modulus
it has to be at least that large that
doesn't
change the complexity of decryption but
what it does
change is the strength of the assumption
that we need to make
q is going to be related
to the size of this lattice and
e the error is going to be the error on
the lattice
and the ratio between them is the
approximation factor that we get
for our lwe instances so
this whole thing with with this setting
of parameter and this way of
evaluating thing this thing would be
security which is based on lwes but not
lw polynomial approximation factor so
we nod was talking about an
approximation factor of n
we're not going to get n here we're
going to get something like n to the log
n
rather so it's a weaker assumption
that a stronger assumption weaker
adversary that needed to break it
than what we could hope for
but it turns out that we can do better
i'm actually not going to go over it
other than saying
why we can do better um the thing that
lets us do better
specifically for the gsw cryptosystem
is this very asymmetric growth of the
noise that we have
remember we multiply two ciphertexts uh
had arrows e1 and e2 we multiplied
e2 by the bit mu1 and multiply e1 by the
matrix
c and g inverse of c it's not one of
them
um so
maybe we can take advantage of this and
this is uh
what uh bakaski and kutanatan did last
year
they show that yes actually you can
build special purpose matrix
a special purpose uh circuit
where all the multiplications have this
property that you multiply some
evaluated ciphertext by a fresh
ciphertext
and the fresh ciphertext is always on
the right and the
the evaluated ciphertext is always on
the left
left so eventually what happens is
every time you do a multiplication like
this the new noise
gets to be your some bit times the old
noise
so either you have the old noise
unchanged or you lose it all together
and then plus m times something that's
a noise of a freshly encrypted
ciphertext so
if you do t of these multiplications
then at most the noise will grow to size
t
times that of a fresh noise and since
your
circuit is of size polynomial then at
the end of the day the noise would only
grow to size polynomials time the noise
of a fresh ciphertext so
overall polynomial in the security
parameter
and therefore also your hardness
assumption that
therefore also the q that you need to
use is only polynomial
and therefore also your hardness
assumption is always going to be is
going to be
lw polynomial approximation ratio
um all right so with that
essentially we're done doing fully
homomorphic encryption
we had gsw for partially homomorphic
homolophic encryption uh we got the
decryption procedure
to be uh of psi of uh depth independent
of the evaluation capacity
by doing the modulus switching trick uh
and using uh
short secret keys and
uh and then we can evaluate
automorphically and get our
bootstrapping process recryption
procedure and get fully morphic
encryption this way
so we have an encryption scheme
where you can evaluate arbitrary
circuits
uh with just one instance of the
encryption scheme whose parameters
uh don't depend on uh
the complexity of the functions that you
want to evaluate and moreover we can do
that
where the uh underlying hardness
assumption that we're making
is lw with polynomial approximation
factors which is as good as we can get
for any lattice based encryption so it's
really uh
in some in that sense it's the the best
possible
uh setting that we can have we can
evaluate whatever we want
the assumption is as uh weak as
as we can hope to ever get it with
current technology
uh and we're done with that so let me
stop here before i move to the next uh
part and if there are any questions
about that part then
i would be a yeah sorry so is the
modulus reduction used
in lieu of uh bootstrapping or is it
complementary no
the the no the modulus reduction at
least in
in this way would you would use it in
order to get the decryption circuit to
be
squat squashed and then you apply
bootstrapping to that
okay so
i'm going to have plenty of time so
let's do something more than that so
remember when i was talking about things
that automorphic encryption schemes do
or do not have
one of the things that it doesn't have
right out of the box is the ability
to compute uh on things that were
encrypted
under different keys so let's see how to
do that and
again we want to keep everything under
the lwe assumption so we'll do that
uh so what is a multi-key homomorphic
encryption
a multi-theomorphic encryption is
an encryption scheme right so we have
the the usual encryption decryption and
key generation but we have something
extra uh
so now instead of having just a single
uh public and secret key we have many
pairs they were generated
independently or close to that at least
we'll see and then we have encryption
under the different keys
and now instead of just an eval
procedure that takes a public key and a
bunch of ciphertext and compute some
circuit
now we have a multi-evol function it
takes
many public keys and ciphertext and
compute
a function on it and
let's stop and think about it suppose uh
cynthia and i wanted to compute it on
our
on our uh separately encrypted um
ciphertext and then we want to decrypt
it which secret key would we need for
that
well definitely you cannot do it without
my secret key because my input was
encrypted under that and you cannot get
it without it
and similarly for cynthia's key so we
need both keys
and that's that holds in general i mean
you would need all of the
all corresponding secret kit in order to
decrypt something that was evaluated
uh from all of these ciphertexts um
so we're going to have this multi
decryption uh
that does that and we want i didn't put
the correctness formula here but we want
the same correctness guarantees as from
the
single uh key or morphic encryption um
the possibility of doing that and the
construction that meets it under
the entry assumption uh some variant of
the interception was
uh done in 2012 by
lopez al trummer and kutanatan
and actually that construction there's a
very obvious way to extend it to do lwe
but it only supports constant number of
i mean the the complexity grows
exponentially with the number of
of parties or you can even get uh
logarithmic many of many parties if you
use
ring lwe based schemes
but here i want to do something a
different construction
that lets you do lwe based
multi-key homomorphic encryption for
polynomially many
players as many as you want and this
follows the construction of
clear and mcgoldrick and and
wix and the presentation that i'm using
is actually from the
letter so
um
yes it could um
and again i mean in this in the original
scheme you actually needed to know the
number of parties ahead of time and then
set your parameters this way
in this scheme i guess we will see this
game and then can decide for it but i
don't think so i think you can
get uh it it does grow but it uh
things only grow you can you can set the
parameters so you can accommodate any
polynomial number of
uh so you can't really do a recrypt on
that right because that would reduce it
to a single key situation
we would actually sort of reduce it to a
single key situation and you can do
recrypt even though i'm not going to
show how to do that
in some sense you do it sort of reduce
it to a single key there will be an
equivalent
single key that's uh that you compute
against
except that this key would depend on all
the secret key of everybody
but you can still do encryption
like first like two people configure
something they do something with the
third person
yes i was trying to think whether this
is the right way to present it and i'm
not sure
because you have to say something about
the structure of the circuit if you're
going to do that i'm
first of all a i'm sure that there is a
way to do it this way i mean there's no
doubt in my mind that if you wanted you
can take your circuit and pre-process it
in in such a way that would make it
uh and b i'm going to show it only for
two two players anyway in this uh
presentation so it's not but uh you but
it's j the construction is general you
can take a construction and it's the
assignment of
uh the public keys to the lead to the
inputs of the circuit and then do it in
one shot
uh if it's uh i think that if
if it is sort of uses different players
in different size then you can walk on
smaller public keys and then make it big
only when they meet
but i'm not sure that's a good way of
doing it didn't think about it
but one way to do this would be to take
each ciphertext your ciphertext
and upgrade it to a ciphertext under the
joint
right so this is this is this is the way
this is the way uh
at least in the the in the paper this is
the way they describe it
uh of course then you know it grows to
the full to the maximum size at the very
beginning so maybe it's not as efficient
okay so we're going to do it's the the
scheme is going to be
uh uh a variation of gsw so just
recall gsw the main reason i wrote it
down is because i wanted to write the
encryption
uh usually we don't really care about
how to do encryption but in this thing
at least from the algebra point of view
it would be important also from the
processing it would be important
the particular way to do encryption and
this is how you do encryption
this is what we said all along i just
never i don't know if i had the formula
before
but uh you take this is my c0
this is uh an um matrix whose rows
are um regular encryptions of zero
uh you take the public key and you take
a 0 1 matrix and multiply it
by it so this is uh this is gsw
encryption
and then you added your bit times this
gadget
matrix g uh b is the public key
uh it has the property that when you
multiply it by the secret here you get
something small
r is a zero one matrix and you have c
times t is mu times t prime plus
something small
uh so the first question maybe we can
add and multiply
these ciphertexts directly not really i
mean you don't get anything meaningful
out of it
uh so the one idea behind it that's the
start of the
of the line is well maybe when you
encrypt you give me a little bit
more information and that would make it
possible later on to combine
uh ciphertext relative to different
public keys
in particular in this case turns out
that what you need
is gsw encryptions of the entries
of this matrix r so i'm going to
use some h some randomness r in order to
encrypt the bit that i care about
and then encrypt the bits of the
randomness
under some other unrelated randomness
and send together the encryption of my
beat and the encryption of all the
random bits that i used
now since i used unrelated randomness in
encrypting the
my randomness then by semantic security
everything goes
right i mean i can't distinguish whether
i encrypted really my randomness or the
zero and if i
if it was the zero then uh regular
semantic security would say that my
beard is encrypted so easy
is hidden so i'm good all right
um so let me start with another rabbit
this is the
the biggest rabbit of the ones that i
describe here
uh at least in the sense that it's
i mean it's a new one in the flock uh i
didn't see it before i don't think i
fully understand it
uh i'll explain it to the the my best
ability to understand it
but there might be a lot more things
that this rabbit can do and we don't
know about them yet
um so let's start with an algebraic
trick
and it's actually easier to describe
this algebraic trick if we go back to
our first try
without the matrix g first and then see
how to uh
to apply it to real gsw later so let's
instead of instead of
r times b plus mu times g we're doing r
times b plus mu times the identity
uh and we have this approximate
eigenvalue eigenvector thing that when
you multiply
uh t by c you get something which is uh
mu times t
plus a little bit of error and notice
that
t is again the first entry here is a one
so the first row of c satisfy the inner
product between the first law of c
and uh and t is just your beat plus a
little bit of error
now that's not doesn't seem very useful
because this is a bit and this is
error bigger than a bit but it would be
turns out to be actually useful
uh so okay let's see
i j be the matrices that encrypt
uh the entries of the matrix rij
okay so we have an a matrix and each bit
of it is encrypted using
the matrix cij uh so the first two by
the same thing we said before the first
row of each one of these matrix uh
satisfy that if you do an inner product
between the first row of the matrix cij
and the secret key
what you get is the bit rij plus a
little bit of error
okay now
let's compute something fix any index i
and fix a particular vector of weights
and what we're going to do is just fix
i go over all the j's and compute a sum
of these vectors c i j with the weights
w
with the weights v why do we want to
compute it well
turns out that it's useful but let's see
what we get
so the inner product between this new
vector that we computed
and our secret key
it's a sum and this each one of these
guys
now it's uh
v j times
uh rij right v right
this one gives us rij plus e so this
thing gives us
v j times r i j plus v j times
whatever error we're using there uh so
that has the form you know it's a vector
and so that sorry that that
that's the this is a vector this is a
single
element and that element is equal to the
inner product between the if
rho of r uh and our
weight vector plus this error term that
we got here
okay so so far what did we do we
computed some
some vectors such that if we try to
decrypt it
what we get is sort of something that
looks related to our randomness
uh with some error term um
now okay let's take all of these
vectors put them together in a matrix uh
and see what this matrix gives us well
the if
uh row here times the vector t
give us the ith row of r times this
weight vector plus
some error term so the entire matrix w
times t give us this thing
that looks a little bit more meaningful
here this
is something related to our randomness
that was encrypted
plus some error terms and the point is
all we needed in order to generate a
matrix w like this
is an encryption of r
and whatever weight vector we want to
apply to it
uh so this so far it's just a trick it's
a weird
property of gsw encryptions well it's
not really a property of gsw encryption
the way i described it
so far this was only the first try uh
this is just an arbitrary weight vector
at this point
we want to it tells us we want to
compute some linear function of our
randomness and v tells us what linear
function it is
yeah except yeah except um
right we you get the actual thing plus
the error
so i mean maybe if you multiply this one
by uh maybe if not
this one by two then you could compete
with mode two but right now it doesn't
really
it's not an encryption in the sense that
you can't really recover the the answer
but
um so okay so far this was the first
try version so it's not really gsw uh
ciphertext yet
and moreover you know this e prime this
l term that we got was an inner product
between a weight vector and the original
error so if our weight vectors is not
small
then this is not small error
so we need to fix it and we're going to
fix it both using the same
g and g inverse that we had before
so let me introduce one more piece of
notation this is our weights
our weights are this vj integers uh
and for each weight now we're going to
give it its own vector we're going to
put it at the first entry of a vector
and fill it up with
zeros uh and with this notation the
thing that we computed before
uh was the vectors w i
was just the sum of these vectors v
j multiplied by the full matrix
ciphertext
so before the this will first try
matrices so it will
square n by n and this was an n vector
uh and then the errors that we got was
an inner product
between these v vectors
and the arrows that we have for the uh
for the encryptions
uh now what we're going to do is we're
just going to apply g to everything so
now these guys are going to be real gsw
matrices
which means that they're these uh skinny
and tall matrices
uh and this thing well this is going to
be g inverse so we take each
entry here and express it uh in bit
representation
uh so the dimensions still match do you
mean that dj is in the jets location
no no it's in the first location i just
i mean this is
this one is a completely syntactic
change i didn't do anything
and it i only did it so that i can show
you why it's so similar to the thing we
get now
um so it's right i mean we still
writing it this way is still misleading
i mean this we take g
inverse of a vector who's mostly zeros
which means we're really only using the
top couple of rows in in the cij
before we were using only the first row
now we're using the log
q top rows of c i j uh
but it's a real gsw ciphertext the
dimensions match because now that we
expanded it it's at them it's a
dimension
m1 which matches the dimensions of rgsw
um and the reason we did that is
now we get good the error behaves much
nicer because
now the new error is the inner product
of old er
error not with the v vector but with
this expanded vector that has only zeros
and ones
uh in our in its uh so
so far i've shown you a trick it's a
nice trick but it's just that so far it
doesn't do much
uh what you show is that given an
element-wise encryption of this
uh 0-1 matrix under some secret key
and giving some arbitrary weight vector
that we want that specifies some
linear function for it we can compute a
matrix w
such that w if you quote unquote decrypt
it
would give you r times v plus a little
bit of error
uh when and the l is one okay this is
yeah you can believe that that would
happen for morphing encryption but it
isn't really homomorphic uh computation
per se
all right before we can use this trick
we need to do one more thing and you and
that is to use
uh public keys that are not quite
independent of each other
so far we could be anything so you're
right uh
set v to be the other guy's public key
something like that
next slide
uh in order to use this trick uh
one thing by the way this maybe there's
another way of doing it
um just this is what we currently know
how to do
um we're going to walk in this common
reference string
our model uh now just
let's just recall very quickly how you
choose a public key for
uh for regiv encryption or gsw for any
of this
uh you start by a random matrix a then
you multiply your secret key
uh by this thing and added add minus the
result
as an another column this is what we
node was showing as
uh finding uh a random matrix a random
matrix where you
uh know a secret uh a short secret uh
one single solution to sis
this is how you choose your uh um your
public and secret keys for jesus so what
hap what
well you're choosing a random matrix
that a that doesn't need to have
anything it just needs to be random
how about everybody use the same a
security is unaffected all the
proofs of security from lw just go right
through in this model because a is
random and this is all you need
you're in the common reference string
now you need to trust somebody to
actually choose this random thing at
random but that's common reference
string for us so we're doing
multi-key folio morphic encryption in
the in the common reference string
all right uh and now all of the public
keys of
everybody are going to have the same a
component and they're only going to be
they're only going to defer in this
first
column that's going to be each one of
them will have their own column
um so okay now we have this
and with that we can start doing things
that are a little more funky
uh by the way there are four steps so
we're almost there
well they sort of get longer as we go
but uh we are in the third out of
four steps
so if you compare this whole expensive
thing to like
using an npc so you save one round
yeah this is uh this this was this was
specifically for saving one run yes
uh even though i would only mention it
in passing at the very end but yeah
um in light of the number of clicks
yeah the tricks are nice the three the
tricks are nice in itself
in themselves and the notion of uh
multi-key or morphic encryption is nice
in itself and may be useful in settings
other than secure computation
or not but uh yeah um
so here we are we
do key generation using the common
reference string
uh this is our encryption still gsw
encryption
r times the public key plus sigma times
g
but we also add for each one of these
matrices that we encrypt this way
we also add gsw encryptions of each
and every individual entry
in our randomness matrix and i'm going
to refer to these
additional encryptions as vector u it's
a vector of matrices if you will
um and this is what we want to do this
is a masking scheme is a scheme where
you can do this
what this is now you have two public key
b and b
prime uh relative to two secret ktm t
prime uh and an encryption relative to
one of them
and now what you want is to come up with
uh just using the seeing the secret key
so seeing the public key and seeing this
expanded
cipher text coming up with this
translation matrix w that would let you
do this
what is this here you have the seek this
here you have the ciphertext that was
encrypted
relative to t but multiplied by the
wrong t
prime here you have what you would have
get if you try to really
decrypt it using t prime if the krypton
decryption worked this is what you would
have get gotten
mu times t prime prime
well g times uh plus a little bit of
error
and what you want is the correction
factor so what we want
is the ability to decrypt it and get the
right answer
decrypted with the wrong key get the
right answer uh using this correction
factor
so that's what we want to do we want
this masking that lets us mask it
uh in we'll unmask it really in this
special way
how do we do that uh okay so we have
these two public keys and they share the
same a
and they only differ in their first
column and delta is this difference
between the two of them
uh and we're going to use our encryption
of the randomness in order to come up
with w
such that w times t is r times the
difference
plus a little bit of error this is where
we're going to use our trick
uh and delta is going to be our weight
vector
y okay let's go see why so first of all
let's
look at this term r times delta
uh what i what i'm claiming is that r
times delta is
really a correction factor it actually
is equal to
r times the distance the difference
between the public key
times the second public the second
secret key
because the difference between these two
public keys
is delta in the first column and zero
elsewhere and this secret key or any
other secret key for that matter
uh has a one here and who cares what it
has here it's gonna multiply by zero
uh so r times delta is really something
that we should care about because it
lets us correct for stuff
and now that we have that let's see what
we get by c
times d prime minus w times t
so you open the two things w times t
is that thing by design c times t
prime well this is c and this is t prime
so i didn't do anything here
um well r times delta we already said
is the same as r times b minus b prime
times t prime so it's that
so other than that i didn't do anything
in this step
uh this is the crucial step this is
where we do the correction here we have
r times b times t prime r times b
times d prime and here we have r times b
minus b
prime times t prime so when you add them
up you get
r times b prime times t prime
and now we notice that b prime times t
prime is just the public key times the
secret key so it's small
and r is a 0 1 matrix so it's small so
all together between these two we have
some small error
and finally we got what we wanted
multiplying this the ciphertext by the
wrong key
adding this correction factor we get the
right answer
great finally we can start talking about
multi-key homomorphic encryption
so didn't you re-encrypt uh ciphertext
encryption routine
to one that centricularity prime not
exactly
because uh we have this correction
factor that we need to multiply by t
let's see
yeah um right staring at it is is
i spend a great deal of time staring at
us trying to see if there's any
thing that i can explain about it but i
didn't see it so
so who puts in the t again we'll see
um right
here is now finally uh what we want to
do
we have a two public keys we have a two
ciphertext
expanded ciphertext
that are encrypted under two different
keys and we want to compute on these two
all right let's look at the
concatenation of the secret keys
this is going to be our new secret key
and let's look at the
double the dimension gadget matrix so
you take your gadget matrix and put it
like this and now you get the gadget
matrix for
dimension which is twice as big
and let's compute w the way we just did
with the masking scheme compute w
such that c times t prime minus w times
t
is this right answer thing here
and finally let double the dimension
ciphertext be the original ciphertext
and the correcting
correction factor here and what we get
now
is take this double dimension ciphertext
multiply it by double dimension secret
key
what you get is c times t at the at the
top and c times t
prime minus w time t at the bottom uh so
exactly what you'd expect you have the t
related stuff here
and the t prime related stuff here and
this is exactly the form that you need
it's mu times g times d prime plus
a prime so this is now
a new ciphertext relative to one
secret key um that encrypts the bit mu
so we took the two ciphertexts that
encrypt we took the c
um and then
you heal and we generated and set
right we took the c and the mu and the b
prime and we generated a new ciphertext
that encrypted the same bit
under a new cipher a new secret key that
depends on both
keys yeah just the concatenation and we
can do exactly the same thing in the
in the other direction we have uh we
compute the w
star w prime such that c prime times t
minus w prime times t prime is
well the right expression with within
the other bit
uh and now we have these two ciphertext
this is the ciphertext that i described
on the previous slide and this is the
ciphertext
from in the other direction and now both
of these ciphertexts encrypt the bit mu
and mu prime under the secret key which
is the concatenation of both
and now we have just two gsw ciphertext
encrypting two different bits under the
same key and we can compute on them
so that's how we get a multi key
and notice that i mean operationally all
we did was
uh well we expanded our ciphertext a
little bit by encrypting also a
randomness
and then we did all of this
transformation and and uh yeah the
dimension grew a little bit
uh but that's pretty much it uh the
construction extend naturally to many
keys
you have to i mean here it was very
clear where to put the w and w prime
otherwise you're gonna have to figure
out where to put them but
you know yeah you play with indexes
until you get what you wanted
you get an encryption under the
concatenation of all the keys
and the dimension and the noise both of
them grow
just linearly with the number of players
uh so you can get this way this thing
gives you a multi-key some automorphic
encryption scheme because so far it's
just some automorphic
uh there is a question of how to do it
fully morphing i mean each
player there has a secret key so it can
encrypt its own
secret key but getting an encryption of
all the keys
well you'll do the same trick you get
encryption of all the keys under the
uh under the key corresponding to the
concatenation of all of them
uh decryption uses the concatenation
of all the keys uh
mukherjee and week's show actually how
to do a one-round threshold decryption
so
each player has only its own secret key
and it sees
the big ciphertext coming out at the end
you just send
one partial decryption and then given
all this partial decryption you can
compute the uh
the decryption of this whole thing and
really just the the thing that each
player sends is an
decryption using its own keys with a
little bit extra noise to hide stuff
um
all right so with that
um i think we are done for
today um so what we
did cover uh in these two hours
so somewhat and fully morphic encryption
it's a useful primitive uh it's
interesting it has all these
properties that you can talk about and
use or not use
um you can construct some automotive
security under lwe and
if you do it uh the parameter size and
the approximation factor that you would
get
is something like security parameter to
the power of the depth that you want to
uh
to achieve you can get fully morphic
encryption of bootstrapping you must
assume circular security to do that
the lw approximation factor that you can
get
naively would be quasi polynomial but
you can get them polynomial if you if
you design the circuit
just the right way uh and you can get
multi-key
somewhat or fully morphic encryption
still with the same
uh yeah the l here is the same
font as the log there um
things we didn't cover today better
efficiency better flexibility
one way to get better efficiency is
instead of working with
high dimension vectors over the integer
work with low dimensional vectors over
extension
rings of the integer it just turns out
that computing
uh um you know a two by two
matrix multiplication over rings of
dimension and
can be done faster than computing an n
by n matrix multiplication
so you get better efficiency this way
once you switch to these rings you can
also pack many plain text element in a
single cipher text
you can use other schemes if you want to
work with different plain text spaces
not just
mode 2 or one thing that i wanted to say
about this packing many things
if you would use gsw you would still get
one plaintext times error and then one
ciphertext times the other error
but the plaintext if it has many bits
packed in it then in terms of its size
it's not so small anymore so you need to
start worrying about the size of that
component as well
um and so basically if you want to use
plain text spaces that are not just z2
then
you better switch to other schemes like
uh
bg uh like bgv or like bukowski or the
entry-based scheme
or something like that uh
things that we didn't cover homophobic
encryption with extra features identity
based on morphic encryption attributes
based on
morphic encryption any other based
homomorphic encryption that you can
think of
uh this is at least something that i
know what it is
here something that i don't even know if
they if they exist is there a notion of
information theoretical morphic
encryption
i'm sure there is i mean we have
information theoretic appearing in
multi-server setting there ought to be a
more
uh information theoretical morphic
encryption too but uh
so i'm sure the answer is yes and you
know making sense of them and what
exists and what not is uh i'm sure there
are people here in the ed in the
audience that know better than me what
is the definition clear or uh
do you have the definition but not the
construction or you don't even have well
i don't have any uh
but uh i'm i'm assuming that there are
people in the audience that do have
definitions in mind
and maybe some construction well peer
you know i mean if you think of peer as
uh
homomorphic encryption in the uh
table uh truth table uh representation
of functions
then you can ask yourself if you can
extend it to more
concise um representations of functions
but uh beyond that point i really don't
know
um yeah i guess it would be the function
that's going to be shared between the
servers
does this exist you know
i'm asking benny because i think he
would know if he does but
all right so yeah thank you